[Musique]
cette nuit pour les insomniaques il y
avait l'élection de miss univers c'est
le mexique qui a gagné la france
représentée par amandine petit a terminé
aux portes du top 10 n'est déjà pas mal
oui si tu as pas mal un peu d'eux
manquant même ouais bon l'eurovision on
espère qu'on fera mieux on fait en cash
comme en été cette soirée elle était
qu'ordinaire évidemment les soirées
scintillante plein de paillettes et une
soirée assez riche en émotions quand
même parce qu'il ya beaucoup de stress
comme sur le sur le plateau de miss
univers mais que du bon stress siturv
est magnifique
si tu pètes suprême il faut faire comme
ça marche
qu'est ce que j'ai envie de faire les
enfants non c'est toi grand film qu'il y
ait un petit temps prévu
qui qui fait aussi que l'on a pris cette
décision d'aller peut-être un peu vite
c'est ça est ce que ben voilà on attend
un petit bébé tu entendes le coeur de
notre petite enfance et les foules moi
je vois plein de gens faire des enfants
au contraire un cauchemar autour de moi
à toulouse génération à tout le monde
fait des enfants
on voit fleurir des petits des petits
raymond autres léopoldine parce qu'il ya
ces prénoms qui reviennent tu sais 1
terrasse du progrès en rue de bretagne à
pariaman appel voilà où j'ai appris que
depuis l'année dernière
vous êtes désormais 3 avec laura bah oui
félicitations merci un petit matane
toyota
moi je ne conçois pas mon existence
comme ça tu es un jeune je ne veux pas
que ma vie soit consacrée à passer chez
naturalia m'acheter les carottes
nécessaire à faire la purée de
leopoldina comment dire ça me met le
cafard françois vous revenez ce soir sur
nouvelle manière de gagner de l'argent
les yeux fermés françois france à chrono
je dors enfin j'essaye c'est vrai que ça
a été un peu longue xavier mais dis donc
radical en effet votre chronique en soit
vous savez que là nous sommes filmés
oui j'espère bien qu'on ait filmé
renault c'est tout l'objectif 1
lorsqu'on est slipstream heures
c'est-à-dire un streamer du sommeil est
aussi que la technologie a pourri le
monde vraiment à ce point là quand ed
mal employés bien évidemment
quel est l'intérêt de regarder quelqu'un
en train de dormir alors ceux qui sont
plutôt insomniaques d'une aide peuvent
trouver un certain réconfort en beau
milieu de la nuit de regarder quelqu'un
en train de dormir en cherchant les
faits soporifique et d'autres qui sont
plutôt sadique en profite pour réveiller
le streamer en lui envoyant mais tout un
tas de bruits complètement désagréable
qui vont de la sirène l'alarmé incendie
voilà vous voyez au chant écossais alors
comment comptent ils tout ça et bien sa
part de l'enceinte connecter une ferme
pas les yeux on apprend les paroles
l'ancien de connecter qu'à l'intérieur
dans le domicile du streamer et c est
bien l'utilisateur qui prend le contrôle
de cette enceinte et se construit le
prends comme en est bien en payant et
c'est comme ça que c'est streamer se
font de l'argent et puis tout s'est fait
news et puis toutes ces ordures qui vous
chie dessus enfin planqués derrière leur
truc enfin si je dire y'a un moment ça
devient un peu pénible de vivre dans un
monde aussi surveiller des autres on
regarde par le trou de la serrure le cul
du voisin moi ça me dégoûte totalement
et on est
on essaie un retour à la milice c'est un
retour à la dénonciation
marine le pen est accusé ainsi que
plusieurs cadres du rassemblement
national de détournement de fonds
publics un pont dans la sphère des
assistants parlementaires européens doit
elle rendre l'argent oui touche pas au
grisbi [ __ ]
non mais ça c'est une expression alors
ça devient plus de la politique c'est du
c'est du spectacle voilà bon c'est un
peu quand même dommage un devoir que
empire complètement la comédie musicale
de gilbert collard ça me permettait ce
réfrigérateur qui dit là pour le coup au
congélateur thé froid vous comprenez
donc qu'il était innocent que ça ne
constitue pas une condamnation si bien
mon raisonnement
donc le contexte familial on s'est dit
que jouer en félicite madame ferrari
le contexte familial qu'elle est il et
bouteilles madame chirac fois que vous
comprenez rien donc on va avoir monsieur
vraiment sans regret pour votre attitude
est votre imprécisions total et meschers
pascal moi je reconnais que je suis un
intermittent du spectacle politique ce
qui est devenu à vocation de tous les
hommes politiques du reste nous sommes
tous des intermittents du spectacle
politique mal payés en plus sur les
plateaux voir pas payer du tout nous à 0
et en plus que je vous paye le lundi
conages allions bien moi je n'en
revenais
rien de temps
sanofi annonce de très bons résultats de
son vaccin candidat avec 95 %
d'efficacité
écoutez le patron du laboratoire
français on va lancer nos essais de
phase iii dans l'est dans quelques
semaines fin du mois de mai début du
mois de juin et simultanément va lancer
notre production simultanément
simultanée d'une production à risque oui
absolument c'est une production à risque
[Applaudissements]
accident
j'aimerais vous dire que que je vais
bien effectivement je vais bien par
rapport aux as et 50 jours mais j'en
chie pardonnez-moi de ce mot mais mais
j'en chie beaucoup à la à la rééducation
je m'entraîne j'ai repris l'entraînement
mais c'est vrai que mes poumons sont
sacrément endommagés en fait les
scientifiques japonais se sont inspirés
du fonctionnement de certaines espèces
comme certains poissons ou araignées de
mer qui ont développé d'autres
mécanismes pour respirer
ils peuvent en effet utiliser leurs
postérieurs pour s'oxygéner afin de
survivre dans des situations d'urgence
des phénomènes qui est désigné par
l'acronyme anglais et va qu'on pourrait
traduire par respiration entérique via
l'anus
la team stress là je les fais tu lances
lima vous vous aimez paix dit
voilà bah ça a le mérite d'être clair
enfin ce top est quand même plus glamour
que l'uniforme d'infirmières de tout à
l'heure ben si on a le choix entre
l'uniforme vilain masculin et le tob
rouge c'est comme choisir entre la peste
et le cholestérol